is a really strong moment right now in
the Twin Cities people believe things
are possible and that is a fertile place
for art to really flourish
there's very much a belief in
possibility but I think also a great
love of doing things collectively like
there's just this strong sense of
communal pride this wanting to come
together and gather and to make things
happen and obviously music and art or
central to what makes people come
together and appreciate culture but also
culture in nature those two things come
together I think
it's a particular moment right now I
think that is that's very exciting and I
think it happens because individuals
believe that there's a platform here and
there's audience a really sophisticated
audience they love to be challenged they
love to discover things that they
haven't experienced before and I think
that spirit comes out of decades of
really culture being such a central
communal value here people really
believe